side and second row courtside speed so  just remember these new policies before  you head on down to the spectrum center  to watch your charlotte hornets ashley  thank you so much and what a beautiful  wrap around dive lamella ball to terry  rozier it's season  four drawing a play and finish  p.j washington throws steven adams to  the floor there's a reason for that  adam's already five offensive rebounds  look at that impressive drive hang right  on the  money to rozier visionary  look away as well  in the pocket deal  hornets had made a couple of changes  nick richards is in early in this ball  game also into the game jalen